Putain.
C'est chaud hein !
On est au bord des ravins.
Oh là là, ne me dis pas
qu'on passe sur ce pont, là.
Pour Brut, je suis dans une zone
extrêment reculée
et très difficile d'accès
du sud de la Colombie.
Une zone qui est tenue par les FARC,
les Forces Armées Révolutionnaires Colombiennes
qui est un groupe qui est considéré
comme terroriste.
Il m'a fallu des semaines
pour arriver jusque là.
Ça y est, on arrive, je crois.
C'est grâce à des journalistes
colombiens que j'ai pu faire ça.
Je vous explique comment
je suis arrivée jusqu'ici.
Je suis désolé, je t'ai fait courir,
comme ça, je t'ai prévenue un peu...
à l'arrache mais...
c'est vraiment un truc qui
nous est arrivé à la dernière minute.
On va avoir une possibilité
et il ne faut pas rater le moment.
On va aller voir les FARC.
Alors, Damien, c’est mon fixeur.
Il est journaliste et traducteur et c’est avec lui
que je bosse quand je vais en Colombie.
On est d'accord,
dans les années 1990-2000,
ils ont kidnappé énormément de gens,
comment on peut être sûrs
qu'on va pas avoir de problèmes
en étant avec eux ?
- Bon alors on a un accord de principe d'eux,
on n'y va pas...
On ne rentre pas comme des fous
dans leur territoire,
on a l'accord
de ce groupe armé pour rentrer
dans le territoire qu'ils contrôlent.
Mais évidemment on n'est pas à l'abri
d'une intervention de l'armée,
d'un bombardement, ce serait le pire
qui pourrait arriver,
ou d'un accrochage, d'une embuscade avec
d'autres groupes rivaux de guérilleros ou
de narcotrafiquants dans la région.
Donc on attend une confirmation
qui dépend des conditions de sécurité.
Quand j'attends le feu vert dans cette chambre,
pendant plus d’une semaine,
je n'ai aucune idée de ce qui m’attend.
Les FARC, j'en savais ce que j'en avais vu
dans les médias quand j'étais adolescente,
un groupe terroriste
qui avait retenu en otage Ingrid Betancourt,
cette Franco-Colombienne, pendant 6 ans
dans les années 2000,
et à l’époque, cette image qui tournait
en boucle dans les médias.
Salut Camille.
Bon, je t'appelle parce qu'on a reçu
des petites nouvelles là,
pas forcément très bonnes pour nous.
Apparemment,
le numéro 2 du front des FARC
s'est fait tuer
hier dans des combats.
Ça risque peut-être de foutre un peu le bordel
dans leur sécurité
et que ça nous retarde encore un petit peu.
Je vous avoue, là, je commence
vraiment à être inquiète.
J'ai l'impression qu'on
ne va jamais y arriver, là.
C'est long.
C'est très, très long.
Salut Camille,
bon ben écoute, j'espère que ton
sac était prêt parce que ça y est,
on a le feu vert.
Ils viennent de nous donner
un premier point de rendez-vous.
Donc je saute dans un taxi et puis
je passe te prendre à l’hôtel.
Ça y est, c'est enfin
le grand jour, on y va.
On est enfin en route avec l’équipe
de journalistes locaux.
Et ce qu’ils m’expliquent me perturbe.
Je ne savais pas du tout que les FARC,
cette guérilla armée historique,
étaient toujours là, en Colombie.
Tu vas voir, déjà ici, ça commence à être
une ambiance un petit peu plus pesante.
Il y a souvent des attentats,
des trucs à la voiture piégée, à la moto piégée.
- Donc oui, on va essayer de rester discrets.
Là, je vais éteindre la caméra
pour un petit moment
et je vous reprends juste après.
- OK.
J’étais persuadée que la guerre en Colombie
s’était terminée avec la signature
des accords de paix en 2016.
Les guérilleros des FARC
avaient rendu les armes,
créé un parti politique
et étaient retournés à la vie civile.
Mais ce que m’explique Damien,
c'est que tous n’ont pas capitulé.
Certains d’entre eux continuent la lutte armée.
Et depuis 5 ans, ils sont en train de se reconstituer
et de reprendre des pans entiers de territoire.
La guerre continue,
il y a toujours des combats chaque semaine,
avec des morts et des déplacés.
Comment j'ai pu passer à côté de cette information ?
En tant que reporter,
ça me paraissait presque irréel.
Le voyage va me paraître interminable.
En fait, le plus compliqué,
c’est de traverser le no man’s land
entre le territoire contrôlé par l'État colombien
et celui contrôlé par les FARC.
On va devoir faire d'énormes détours
de plusieurs centaines de kilomètres
pour éviter l’armée et d’autres groupes rivaux,
et éviter de se faire arrêter.
On n’a vraiment aucune certitude d’y arriver.
Bon voilà, en fait, hier,
on a fait plus de cinq heures de route
de nuit, sous la pluie battante,
pour arriver dans ce petit village,
où on a passé la nuit.
Et voilà, on peut voir ce genre de panneau
un peu partout sur la route.
"FARC-EP", donc "Armée du Peuple",
et le front Carlos Patiño,
qui est le nom du front qu’on va aller voir.
Alors ce qu’il faut savoir, c’est qu’ici,
il n'y a vraiment pas du tout
de présence de l’État,
il n'y a pas de police, il n'y a pas d’armée,
mais il n'y a pas non plus d’hôpitaux,
d’écoles, de services publics, de routes.
Ça a vraiment un air de far-west.
Donc là vraiment on est au cœur
du pays qui est contrôlé par les FARC.
On est escortés par des hommes armés,
je ne peux pas montrer leurs visages.
Et en fait là tous les champs que vous voyez,
toutes les plantations,
c’est des plantations de coca,
donc c’est la plante qui sert à faire la cocaïne.
Je vous en parlerai plus
dans une prochaine vidéo.
Donc là, on part vraiment au fin fond
des montagnes colombiennes.
Je ne sais pas exactement où je vais et
ils me demandent de garder l’endroit secret.
Alors là, on est en train d’arriver sur un campement FARC.
Ils sont par petits groupes de vingt
ou trente cachés dans la forêt.
Il ne faut absolument pas, évidemment, dévoiler le lieu.
Bon, ils nous ont complètement interdit
de montrer les visages des gens qui sont ici,
mais bon, après négociations,
on va pouvoir interviewer l’une d’entre elles.
Et en fait, Mariana, elle a tout juste 18 ans aujourd’hui.
C’est son anniversaire, du coup,
ils lui ont préparé une petite surprise.
À ce moment-là, je me pose encore plein de questions.
Depuis quelques années, les FARC recrutent
énormément de jeunes comme Mariana.
Qu’est-ce qui peut les séduire dans cette organisation
pour les pousser
à sacrifier une partie de leur jeunesse ?
Ça y est, on arrive, je crois.
C'est le campement, là.
Alors là, on s’est levés à 4h30
en même temps que les nouvelles recrues,
qui vont prendre leur petit déjeuner
et commencer leur entraînement.
On a l’interdiction formelle d’allumer de grosses lumières
parce qu’ils ont très peur d'être repérés par l’armée.
C’est déjà arrivé que l’armée bombarde
ou attaque des centres de formation.
Alors, ce que vous voyez derrière moi, c’est donc la formation des nouvelles recrues.
Ils sont une cinquantaine là.
Et ils restent ici à peu près
trois mois à se former
avant de partir vraiment sur le front.
Pour le moment ils ont des fusils en bois,
en attendant d’avoir des vraies armes,
évidemment, pour partir à la guerre.
Les FARC sont souvent accusés
de recrutement forcé,
et en discutant avec ces jeunes recrues,
je découvre que certains d'entre eux
sont en fait mineurs.
Les plus jeunes ont à peine 15 ans.
J’ai du mal à croire que Stephany et Michael
vont partir au front d’ici quelques semaines.
Ils me paraissent encore tellement jeunes.
J’essaye de mettre à la place de Stephany,
à son âge,
et je me demande comment elle envisage
son futur en tant que femme.
- Et plus tard, t'aimerais peut-être
avoir des enfants ?
Je trouve ces jeunes hyper courageux
de vivre dans des conditions pareilles,
juste par conviction.
Mais je me demande
si la cause qu’ils défendent
n’est pas un peu trop grande pour eux,
à leur âge.
Ce que je comprends sur place,
c’est que les FARC, c’est pas juste
un groupe armé perdu dans la jungle.
C’est aussi une force politique
qui essaie de convaincre dans les villes
et les villages.
Alors, les FARC, ils ont aussi
des cellules politiques clandestines,
des personnes qui sont complètement
incognito dans la population civile.
L’un d’entre eux nous a donné
rendez-vous dans cette petite maison.
Il va arriver masqué
car personne ne doit savoir qui il est.
- Et est-ce que votre propre famille
est au courant de ce que vous faites ?
Les paramilitaires, ce sont des milices d’extrême droite.
Selon différents rapports de l’ONU et d’ONG,
ils seraient responsables de 80 % des morts
depuis le début de la guerre en Colombie.
Ils sont réputés pour leurs massacres,
contre des guérilleros, bien sûr,
mais surtout contre des civils,
notamment des leaders sociaux.
Damien m’avait montré cette affiche,
avec les noms
des personnes les plus recherchées du pays,
considérées comme les "symboles du mal"
par le gouvernement colombien,
avec les visages des chefs des FARC.
Après plusieurs semaines de négociations,
j’allais enfin pouvoir rencontrer Jhonier,
un des plus grands commandants.
Sa tête est mise à prix pour l’équivalent
de 700 000 euros par le gouvernement.
Quelques semaines après cette interview,
j'apprends que Jhonier est abattu
dans une opération de l’armée.
Le président colombien, Iván Duque, annonce
sa mort en direct à la télévision.
Ce jour-là, je n’imagine pas du tout
que c’est sa dernière interview.
Les FARC assument.
Ils se financent principalement
grâce à l’exportation de la cocaïne.
Quand je passe beaucoup de temps
sur le terrain,
j’ai toujours peur de m’attacher aux gens
et de ne plus être assez neutre.
Mais il ne fallait pas que j’oublie
que les FARC participent au narcotrafic
et qu’ils sont souvent accusés
de crime de guerre.
À la fin de ce voyage,
j’ai l’impression de commencer à comprendre
ce qu’il se passe ici,
en Colombie.
Le gouvernement, d’extrême droite,
s’oppose à plein de groupes armés
d’extrême gauche,
dont les FARC.
Et au milieu de tout ça,
il y a une population pauvre
qui essaye juste de survivre.
J'espère que vous avez apprécié cette vidéo
et surtout que vous avez appris des choses.
Si c'est le cas, n'hésitez vraiment pas
à vous abonner.
Et comme je vous le disais
à un moment dans le documentaire,
j'ai aussi fait une vidéo sur la production
de la cocaïne en Colombie
qui est disponible dès maintenant
sur ma chaîne YouTube.
Je vous mets le lien juste après
et en description
et je vous dis à très bientôt.